I hope you like guns because we've got
plenty of those this week also dinosaurs
and sports alright I guess you don't
have to like guns but it helps anyway if
you want to know about all the latest
games gun filled or not be sure to hit
that subscribe button here are the big
new releases for this week
remember those guns I was talking about
strafe has a bunch of them and it takes
its cues from ninety shooters like doom
and quake but with some roguelike
elements and procedural generation the
random arrangement of rooms could hold a
sweet new weapon or introduce you to a
merchant with upgrades for sale your
whole goal as a scrapper is to explore a
spaceship where something went terribly
wrong but that's really just an excuse
to blast away some aliens and quasi
64-bit arenas and for the most hardcore
players you can also do that in VR
thanks to the oculus rift strafe comes
to ps4 and PC on Tuesday May 9th Harvest
Moon is a far cry from space violence
and birthdays the beginning comes from
the same creator
it's a cube-shaped game where you can
build your own garden paradise think
Harvest Moon Meets Minecraft it's a
place where humans dinosaurs and many
other animals coexist and you can
collect almost 300 different creatures
to populate your custom-built world
birthdays also has challenge modes if
you're looking to chase high scores or
best times in your garden you can give
that all a go on ps4 and PC on May 9th
and now it's time for your mid video
Sports report NBA playgrounds is being
compared to the fan-favorite NBA Jam and
for good reason
this two-on-two basketball game features
players from all different eras with
more coming down the road
they've all been treated to a goofy
big-headed art style and some sweet
over-the-top dunks NBA playgrounds
features single player and both local
and online multiplayer along with some
alternate game modes so you've got
plenty of options for showing off your
skills you can jump in on PA
for Xbox one PC and Nintendo switch on
May 9th now back to your regularly
scheduled violence with dead cells this
roguelike is inspired by both
Castlevania and Dark Souls which means I
get to use this montage again you will
die a lot
but the helpful thing about dead cells
is that the farther you get the more
tools you'll unlock to help you get back
where you died faster
there are even special doors that are
only open for a limited time
perfect for speedrunners dead cells
comes to steam early access on Wednesday
May 10th but you can check out some
gameplay on GameSpot right now and we're
closing out with more guns
remember those butcher is not about the
guy you buy your fresh meat from it's a
2d action shooter that takes its cues
from 90 shooters like doom and quake now
where have I heard that before
and it takes its cues from 90 shooters
like doom and quake butcher gives you
all the tools for a bloody good time
chainsaws lava pits and 20 levels full
of monsters just begging to be brutally
taken down the game launched on Steam
last year but you can get your hands on
the ps4 version on Tuesday May 9th and
the Xbox one version the following day
and those are the big games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week